this one's not long she goes and we're  having a barbecue and she goes have you  seen my cat my dad said would you  recognize it barbecue and just a horror  on her face anyway she walked off she  called the police the police officers  came my dad got an argument accusations  because he was drunk and he got arrested  only a cat owning [ __ ] would complain  to the police about [ __ ] joke fine  you're upset you lost your cat fair  enough yeah the joke maybe a little bit  you know risque who calls the police on  a [ __ ] joke cat owners cat owners are  liberals cow owners believe in hate  speech cat owners are Democrats cat  owners are kids that is mostly true I'm  not saying it's without exception or  it's not without exception rather but  exceptions prove rules I think he's  right about the cats